thank you all for coming
thrown under there addition of a
beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
comer today we'll be going over games
that called don't trap your queen okay
so so don't lose your queen a big way
that you lose your queen is you get it
trapped okay it's got no place to go
all right so remember you want to keep
your queen mobile and out of harm's way
okay so we just took the chess club just
concluded hosting the u.s. junior close
championship it had 10 extraordinary
young men competing for prize fun of
$10,000 the winner was a Kaden trove he
just recently got his Grandmaster title
he won $3,000 and he'll get an entry
into the 2015 US Chess Championship also
to be held at the Chess Club so here is
this final round game his big win
against local st. Louis resident Matt
Larson Canaan trophy is playing the
white pieces okay so he starts out d4
all right and black counters d5 the
lowest percentage win of all blacks
responses okay but all right but that
doesn't mean it's bad all right
so white brings out his knight to f3 not
playing c4 so black counters with Knight
to f6 white plays III everybody that's
been watching our programs the last you
know two three months
knows that I am NOT a fan of III can
anybody tell me why I'm now a fan of e3
yeah cuz you made your bishop once the
one not very mobile okay but he's a
grandmaster so who's to argue with with
him okay so so alright so he's like okay
Matt Larson's thinking I'm not gonna
make the same mistake that my opponents
make I'm gonna get my bishop
okay and now that this pawn is on you
know not on c4 he doesn't have to worry
about Queen to b3 here okay because if
white could play Queen to b3 right now
targeting b7 Matt would be in trouble
but since he brought his Knight out
brought his little pawn L he doesn't
have to worry about it so Bishop f5 so
now c4 so now he's not threatening that
he's also threatening to bring his Queen
to b3 so so now black plays c6 alright
so it supports this pawn and also how do
you think he would cover how do you
think black were to respond to Queen to
b3 in this position and I'll give you a
hint it has something to do with this
last move which was c6 Queen to c7 good
alright it protects the pawn and he
still has plenty of defenders on d4 okay
so now he prepares it with Knight to c3
alright so he now he's adding another
attacker on to d5 so right now he's got
one two and he's preparing Queen to b3
adding a third one through an x-ray okay
so double prepared now he plays a six
and guess what this Bishop isn't
relegated to the back row right so Matt
Larson he's probably smiling right now I
got all my guys protected and life is
good okay so you see how black in this
position because white didn't play c4
right away was able to get his bishop
free okay so who do you think blacks
gonna win in this position considering
you did everything good not quite but
but that's okay so now white brings out
his knight to attack the bishop so do
you think black really wants
to happen no okay so so he doesn't want
that to happen
so you can just retreat the bishop these
double pawns is what Kaden gives them so
now he's got double pawns but you see
how these double pawns are better than
the ones that look like that look like
this see the difference now Knight takes
bishop this rook is now active he's got
play along the H file so if Kaden as
white ever castles over there
he might have checkmate threats on this
h-file okay all right so now Bishop
attacks this pawn but it's protected so
he's doing all right so he doesn't
really have to worry about that too much
so now he continues his development
so now castle so as black I'd be kind of
happy right now you know I got this
h-file open targeting the square here
and things are going okay so if black
really wanted a thread checkmate in this
position what would he do okay so so
have you moved the horse
it doesn't actually threaten checkmate
and also it would let them get captured
okay but but it's okay idea so the idea
is wow I want to attack h2 unfortunately
even if even if your dreams come true
even if you take on h2 it's still not
checkmate
all right so we want to get the Queen
down there all right so where can the
Queen go right now you in the white
shirt where can the Queen go right now
to a thread checkmate
very good c7 all right so that that's an
idea but instead he decides to play
Bishop to d6 all right a threatening
perpetual check check King there check
King there so here wasn't going for the
win out evidently he wanted just the
perpetual check all right so Bishop to
d6 so now how do you think Kaden as
White says I'm not going to let you take
H to g3 not quite he plays h3 okay and
that stops the nightie from coming in
even more all right
well not actually not quite but okay so
so now he stopped at that threat so now
he plays his Bishop back to c7 he
doesn't want to get attacked I guess all
right and maybe he's making his way in
for the Queen there alright so b3 g5 all
right so he's threatening to play pawn
here because if if he just ignores it
and plays g5 then he can force even
though he's sacrificing a knight here do
you see how he's forcing a draw here
check just and you do this three times
and they just call it they don't make
you do it on and on and on and on and
then it's a draw and considering Matt
Larson is a national master
I don't think he'd be too too ashamed if
he just drew a grandmaster came true
alright so that's what the threat is so
white counters wit by taking the pawn
here and now Matt kind of four goes as
planned and plays Knight takes
interesting alright maybe you didn't
even want to draw maybe he wants to get
his queen to d6 and checkmate them so so
Knight takes pawn takes and so good
alright if you've been following my
lectures here if your king is in a
castle and his king is in the center you
want to break open the center at all
cost okay so he does that by efore so
takes bishop takes so now the center is
open okay so now black plays Knight f6
attacking the knight all right and now
his queen is free to go to d6 and now
white plays rook to e1 so notice no you
should notice that the e-file is now the
action file because that's where all the
action is okay so rook Bishop King I
moved the bishop check right I mean how
hard is this alright so as black should
you be scared of this old man if he
moves the bishop anywhere I'm in check
you want to just let this happen you
don't want to get discovered check do
you no no heck no so what should you do
move the King where do you suggest the
King move they could Castle short okay
that's what I want to played because how
good is your King side attack anyway but
instead Matt Larson takes a gamble he's
like well I plan a Grand Master you know
I'm mathematically eliminated from
winning the junior championship anyway
I'm just gonna go for it Queen the d6
threatening not checkmate by the way
okay if he was threatening checkmate
it'd be something so so now Kane's like
alright awesome I probably would have
thought it this move for about two
seconds at the most an hour just played
it where do you think white plays in
this position yeah Bishop takes c6 not
just one check double check all right
you got two checks going so he can't
legally take this because the King would
still be in check whenever you were in
double check there's only one way to get
out of double check you have to move the
King you can't black two checks at once
and you can't capture two pieces okay so
he's got to move his King King to f8
okay alright so now hey I might as well
take another poem right now okay so now
I'm up to pawns all right so now Matt
Larsen gets his gets us check King here
well that might not check them again oh
okay well because it does nothing and
you lose your rook okay so see if you
check them again here is a bad move cuz
King here and now I'm threatening to
take your queen and I'm also threatening
Bishop takes rook makes sense
okay so sorry I'm gonna move my rook to
d8 first okay then I'll play check
that's a minute so gains like okay so
Bishop goes to b6
Queen to f3 protecting the bishop and
adding another attacker to this night so
Bishop attacks the rook Bishop retreats
he's like you wanna trade we'll trade so
he's calling his bluff he's going so
okay so now Matt Larson plays the check
okay cuz cuz guess what yeah I'm your
Queens attack okay so check so King to
e2 rook check King moves rook takes rook
takes Queen have anywhere to go
to eat one yeah yeah all right so we
don't want to trade a queen for a rook
so what else dough no yeah
so his queen is now trapped it's on this
back row and nothing nothing good is
happening he could try this rook takes
pawn takes Queen takes Bishop takes but
that would still leave him down a whole
Rock so not very good okay so so Matt
Larson unfortunately got his Queen Queen
trapped down there he cut off his his
escape diagonal see he had this whole
diagonal so he thought he was doing
pretty nice but by playing Bishop there
blocks it in and then not good so we'll
see a game kind of similar to that how
we trap the Queen okay we're ready for a
game - this is a game I played as black
against a guy rated around a thousand
okay and of course I win by trapping his
queen okay so II 4 C 5 so this is the
Sicilian defense I play it kind of weird
I play d6 I usually play Knight to c6
but yes I play d6 it's all it's all good
night to c3 so you're like Oh Mike
you're really bad way right why are you
trapping in your bishop alright so I had
no intention of getting my Bishop out on
this diagonal so how do you think I do i
fee and shadow it with g6 okay no g6 so
he plays g3 which is kind of unusual
he has the express lane out to a check
or to c4 and he decides to play g3 ok so
very unusual Bishop to g7 Bishop g2
Bishop g4 pens the night he plays d3 and
now Queen to d7
I'm putting the Queen and the bishop
when they're on the same file it's
called a diagonal or not edit that okay
when when when the Queen and Bishop are
on the same diagonal it's called a
battery alright so that's a bad for you
okay
the battery alright so white castles and
the good thing about this battery is uh
you can play Bishop down there and then
you can trade the bishops which is what
I play okay because once you get this
guy out of there and I'll be way easier
to check make your opponent alright so
he plays Knight to h4 which is kind of
an unusual move here so Knight to c6
gets his Bishop out but it's not doing
too much so now I want to get castles so
I play Knight f6 and now I'm thinking
when he plays Knight to h4 he's gonna
play play F 4 and then f5 okay but
instead he plays Queen to f3 okay so I'm
like that's kind of unusual
all right so how do you think I take
advantage of hemp playing the dubious
Queen to f3 alright so one suggestion is
g5 attacks tonight I take your bishop
and I'm attacking your queen and if you
play here
I'll just take night takes and I'm I'm
up a pawn okay so so remember the the
name of the lesson is don't lose your
queen
so Bishop to g4
is that what you say okay Bishop the g4
okay so now the Queen's under attack and
you can't retreat through the diagonal
alright so there's only one square that
doesn't lose right away for him and
that's after four now does anybody have
any ideas see how the Queen doesn't have
many legal squares to go to well that
doesn't just outright lose them so does
anybody have any ideas now to corral
this Queen which one night two h5
and then the queen would have to go here
then what would we do
anybody got any ideas and you just say
wow man you escaped you're good and
maybe you did escape I don't know it's
gonna be close now app-6 don't so hot
that's a bad word in this class alright
but he said f6 so we have to go go with
it
f6 you better hope you better hope this
works so this this looks like a good
square for my queen and I'm feeling
pretty good right now I'm feeling so
good but alright but I shouldn't feel
good because you got Bishop to e6 and
you finally got them
you finally got them Queen can't retreat
to the dangle so you see how it's cool
so it looks like in these last two two
games that bishops are really cool at
train to win Queens because they they
take away a lot of their flight squares
okay alright so in the game I did not
play Knight here I just went for the
straight forward e5 and now he plays a
humourist move what do you think white
would play in this position if you had a
guess the Queen's chief I have it's that
Aegis I go straight for it it just just
let us Queen get home okay I almost
played a really funny move and not even
took it and played castle cuz if he goes
back I play h6 but then I was like well
you know if he's just gonna give me a
queen why not I just I just take it even
I guess my better judgment but however
so now he takes it and now he's got the
big threat Bishop the g7 okay and now I
can't castle so maybe I should have
Castle when I had the chance but um but
my opponent plays even funnier than that
okay so after I take you
sides not to take back which kind of
surprised me
he plays Knight to d5 okay so he's
hoping that I play something and then he
plays Knight takes check forty mike-mike
Queen yeah my king and gets my okay so
so obviously I could just take his
knight but then he would take and now
he's attacking my knight so he just lost
a full queen and he thought he was being
cute with this
Intermezzo move so instead of being down
to a queen for a bishop he's just down a
queen right now so if I can just keep
that I'll be up a full Queen for nothing
so what uh what move what move should I
play to just keep all my advantage and
by the way my opponent is is a guy he's
been in the audience a few times in
Grandmaster Ben Feingold's lectures
that's always a raisins hand and it's
shining out the wrong answer so so uh so
you guys should like it that I'm
crushing this kid alright so what uh
what move should I make I don't want to
lose my bishop I don't want to lose my
knight obviously so what move should I
make here that way I'm just up a whole
queen for nothing I don't have to give
back any of my material the do you have
it
no okay okay
follow how about you
it can't be a pawn move cuz he's got a
serious threat right now Knight takes
Knight check and then Knight takes Queen
alright so so basically there's two
things we want to do right we could
eliminate the knight but unfortunately
that doesn't get our piece back Hey
ninety-two GA okay Knight the g8 Sonny
but it loses because I'll just take do
you want to take back no because then he
gets the fork okay because I Castle
doesn't work either that Castle just
leads to a disaster so you see how fast
you can go from being +9 de to negative
five probably all right so every castle
on the other side he'll still just take
our Knight
you're making me look like a genius here
with my move okay
h5 isn't even legal
alright so so let's see what's going on
in this position okay so so Abby's at
home since since I would just say hey
all right just just eliminate the threat
and and just be up a queen for a night
then okay but but we can find this i I
know we can find this so whites threats
or Knight takes Knight check and take
the Queen right and there also
Bishop takes Bishop right all right so
well if I give you this hint you can't
miss it
right alright so Bishop the g7 is the
move the hint is move the bishop out of
danger and protect your knight
all right so yeah that's much better
than taking the night then castling
especially castling short and and now
all he can take is your night and we can
take it right back and so we're up a
whole queen for absolutely nothing so
this should be a very very easy game all
right
so so now he plays a Bishop h6 so do you
think we should take it no it's a trick
all right so if we take it then he gets
our knight and then our queen okay so
now what moves should we play castle
good long Castle short castle excellent
well short castle so now so now we're in
a great great shape so Knight takes up
six Czech Bishop takes so he gets our
rook but we're up so much material it
really doesn't matter so rook takes up
fate h3 attacks our Bishop so what
should we do just take the pawn we count
up he's got one defender we got two
attackers so we can just take it so he
takes Queen takes and now we should be
thinking about Chuck mate he plays a
really good move here so if you had two
free moves I'm gonna give black two free
moves here
how would you checkmate white here if it
was black the move and he has two free
moves
I joined excellent
you don't like Knight to e2 well
actually it does make a big difference
Knight f3 doesn't work cuz Knight takes
Knight huh
so Knight to e2 alright so so you saw
how black has a checkmate in two moves
so white has been making a lot of us
back
moves to say the least but he makes a
really good move in this position
because he doesn't want to get checkmate
in two moves why do you think he makes C
three excellent okay so see your
opponents threats and react to them
alright but but it's fine
Queen takes and now I could just take
this pawn huh but I want to take it with
check how in the world can I take this
part with check anybody have any ideas
yeah Steven Scott Stevens like oh yeah
easy yeah so so check King takes check
King takes okay see if you can just take
something with check then it's fun okay
but when I decide not to take it I think
I have better I am f5 so who do you
think I really want to take that pawn
with because if I take it with the Queen
it's not checkmate
right yeah if I can somehow take that
with the rook I'll be aces alright so he
plays h5 so he's not letting me do that
so Queen takes h5 check King to g1 so
pawn takes e4 pawn takes e4 and let's
see if you guys can configure this one
out what do you think black plays in
this position yes
all right work the f3 I was thinking
about ideas like this but unfortunately
then he can move his other rook let's
say he goes all the way to b1 whatever
and then it's gonna be really tough for
me to checkmate him okay because guess
what he can go to f1 and then he can get
out so I don't want him to get out okay
I do not want him getting his King to f1
ever ever
so what move do you think I should play
Queen to h3 wait wait wait what are some
other suggestions like we need to he's
like okay whatever
how am I gonna checkmate him then if my
Queens on you too bright but but doesn't
prevent my work from going there though
and then you should go back and they
guess where his King goes oh shucks
what's up oh never mind
yeah yeah so so he had a really funny
suggestion I presume producer up and
Simon had a good move here if I chose
Queen to be true and I goes there I'm
gonna take check and just just win win a
lot okay so that's pretty good so Queen
to e 2 is okay but maybe I'll put my
other maybe I just ignore you and play a
four no no what
okay okay so Stephens got it so play
Queen of G for right now and then he's
got to go
well h1 or h2 and now now what what's
your move after it perfect okay
rook g1 and how can we put on the final
touches rook h3 checkmate
excellent okay all right fantastic so so
you saw how how in the game he lost his
queen here so the way he lost his queen
was very very early on in the game he
played his Queen to f3 and it kind of
boxed him in he only has 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
legal moves with his Queen and of those
seven only one two three of them are any
good ok
the rest of them he'll get taken okay so
so we attack and luckily we attacked not
as not just as Queen but also his flight
squares okay where he could get away and
so now he's got go here and then we got
him okay
in this position everybody went through
that the reason why it didn't go there
as Peter knows cuz Bishop takes Bishop
and now I'm threatening your queen but
it was a decent idea but it it's better
just to attack right away we got time
for one more game anybody want to see
one more game all right let's see it and
this one's really easy okay
that's laughable how easy it is okay but
I'm playing a rank amateur in this game
and I have the black pieces efore c5
Knight f3 knight c6 alright Bishop the
d3 not the most best place for this
Bishop huh and it's basically acting
like a pawn and stopping this pawn from
advancing much better our c4 or even b5
alright not d3 though t6 now he decides
since he can't get his [ __ ] about this
way to play b3 okay so you see how one
mistake it just compounds and compounds
and compounds and now because you made a
mistake of not getting your D pawn to d4
and your bishop out you have to make
other adjustments in the game and this
is not the best place for your bishop
here all right Knight f6 Bishop to b2 no
actually first he plays he castles okay
all right so Bishop to g4 so it pins the
night here okay so Knight to c3 g6
Bishop to b2 so Bishop to g7 so we got
our bishops all on this a long diagonal
so there could be a potential tactics
coming up all right so he plays the move
e5 all right he only has one defender on
this and I have two attackers so Knight
takes e5 and this is a way people end up
losing their Queens to Knight takes e5
what should black play here move the
bishop yeah you're right move the bishop
so they have AC the move we should play
so sometimes this is I know you got it
yeah just take sometimes they forget a
pieces in a pin and then it all falls
apart so always look what's in the same
line as you know your king and your
power pieces like your Queen and the
rook and make sure oh man my Knights and
a pin I better not
move it all right so Brooke takes the
one pawn takes e5 and it just gets
pretty bad from here Bishop check Knight
to d7 or deed anyone and see how hard it
is to play when you're down a queen even
if even if you have a piece for it
Castle Knight to d5 attack the bishop
we love trades when we're up material we
love them okay
Knight to b6 even though we get fork so
that's the second time I got up Queen
and then I give it all back because I
give back in exchange I did it in the
first game I did it in the second game
when you're up it doesn't mean it's time
to relax okay cuz you're still playing a
game okay
just ask ask anybody it's tough it's
tough
all right so Knight to be six but we're
still doing okay Knight takes a 8 Queen
takes c2
Bishop takes e5 Bishop takes rook takes
it takes eight rook takes seven rook the
d8 and and yeah it's pretty much it's
pretty much a done deal here I mean it's
not gonna last too much longer
what should a black play in this
position just to try to try to get it
get it over with
rook the d1 okay and does he have any
good defense to this or is a pretty much
game set match
good check right that do anything no
it's a spy check but yeah
there's no way there's no good way to
get out of here so you have to lose this
rook because if work takes Queen takes
checkmate
and so g3 is much better than h3 in that
position but it's too late you already
play h3 you took his hand off cuz up
so yeah in this position the correct
move is g3 excellent job say you're
learning you're learning all right thank
you all for coming to another edition of
a beginner breakdown try not to lose
your queen